في قائمه منصه شاهد للاعمال الاكثر مشاهده
في السعوديه استطاع مسلسل جعفر العمده
لبطله محمد رمضان ان يتصدر القائمه مسلسل
طاش العوده هو الجزء التاسع عشر للمسلسل
الشهير احتل المرتبه الثانيه في نفس
القائمه فله مسلسل الاطاره والتشويق
اللبناني واخيرا وهو من بطوله النجم
اللبنانيه نادين نجيب والنجم السوري قصي
خولي فيما احتل المسلسل والسعودي بجزئيه
الثاني منه ولدنا المرتبه الرابعه من
القائمه وجاء المسلسل المصري الازهر للنجم
عمرو سعد في المرتبه الخامسه اما العمل
التاريخي الاضخم سفر فجاء في المرتبه
السادسه من هذه القائمه يليها في المرتبه
السابعه مسلسل الدراما الخليجي مجاريح وهو
من بطوله سعاد عبد الله مسلسل دفعه لندن
الذي اثار الجدل منذ بدايه عرضه بين
العراقيين والكويتيين جاء في المرتبه
الثامنه من هذه القائمه ايضا مسلسل
الدراما الكويتي منزل 12 جاء في المرتبه
التاسعه واخيرا وليس اخرا في المرتبه
العاشره من قائمه الاعمال الاكثر مشاهده
على منصه شاهد في السعوديه جاء المسلسل
الكوميدي السعودي استوديو 23
[موسيقى]